like I said at the end of my last video
I am going to make some noise in this
channel so I guess I'll just go ahead
and jump into that right now
but first you may have seen the recent
headlines in the news regarding the NASA
discovery of a massive 19 mile wide
crater found hidden underneath
Greenland's Hiawatha glacier this crater
is a result of an asteroid impact from a
nearly 1 mile wide mountain of iron
weighing somewhere around get this 11 to
12 billion tons and was traveling at
approximately 12 miles per second which
is equivalent to more than 43,000 miles
per hour when it slammed into the earth
some 12,000 years ago and with the
mind-boggling force of essentially a 700
Megaton bomb and without a doubt this is
the reason why there is so much mystery
and why we know so little about lost
ancient human civilization as this event
was so extreme that whatever existing
civilizations were around at that time
faced a massive reset button sending
them essentially back to the Stone Age
in erasing so much of ancient history in
a blink of an eye in fact to truly
appreciate just how significant this
event was to Planet Earth
the people animals and vegetation living
on it let me make a few comparisons to
what a seven hundred Megaton explosion
would do example number one the atomic
bomb dropped on Hiroshima in 1945 was
absolutely devastating as it flattened
an entire city in an instant and was
equivalent to 15 kilo tons of TNT and in
case you're not familiar with the math
on this this is essentially a very small
fraction to the power of a one Megaton
bomb but again that 15 kilo tons was
catastrophic aliy destructive for a
radius of approximately one mile
now that's considered the notable air
burst that happened over Russia in 2012
which the fireball itself glowed 30
times brighter than that of the Sun this
rock was only 20 meters wide or 66 feet
yet it blew up in the atmosphere at an
equivalent yield of 400 to 500 kilo tons
again compare that to the just 15
kilotons of the her Oshima blast an
estimate suggesting that it was
essentially 26 to 30 times more energy
than the Hiroshima event powerful enough
to seriously injure more than 1500
people and damaged 7,200 buildings
across six cities but thankfully it
exploded in the atmosphere some 18 and a
half miles up which significantly
buffered the amount of damage that it
would have otherwise cost and here is
all that was left of the original 20
meter rock that hit the ground
absolutely nothing compared to the 19
mile wide crater in Greenland let me
give you another example to really paint
you a picture of the point I'm about to
make the Tunguska event of 1908 was
another air burst that occurred over a
remote region of Siberia a flattened
massive trees for 800 square miles
essentially equivalent to a 10 Megaton
bomb which was 1,000 times more powerful
than the Hiroshima blast even to this
day more than 110 years later
evidence of this blast is still apparent
there is even a nearly 1,000 foot wide
circular piece of land at its at the
center where vegetation will still not
grow to this day so when we consider the
newly discovered Hiawatha crater in
Greenland being 19 miles across and a
thousand feet deep and was hit by a 1
mile wide piece of iron weighing as much
as 12 billion tons and traveling at 12
miles a second again equivalent to a 700
Megaton blast is it even possible for us
to comprehend the devastation that this
would cause throughout the world upon
impact and listen to this even if the
massive chunk of iron that caused this
crater was only 10 billion tons which
was the conservative estimate it would
have still generated energy of 47
million times stronger than that of the
Hiroshima bomb that's right
47 million times stronger and this was
said to have happened when man existed
on earth between 100,000 and 12,000 800
years ago and of course scientists
usually give approximations and ranges
of time but in this case there really
should be no doubt at all that this
event happened at that 12,000 year mark
as the information I'm about to share
with
you is so overwhelming that you will
have no doubts but what's crazy is that
this evidence has already existed for
years but has been shunned by the
mainstream scientific and academic
communities which yes absolutely does
exist just as it always has because
there have been numerous examples
throughout history where the groupthink
mentality have ridiculed the works of so
many brilliant people only to be
vindicated years later
I mean Copernicus presented evidence
that the earth rotated around the Sun
and that the Sun did not rotate around
the earth and he was shunned Galileo
built off of his evidence to straight-up
prove it as fact but was going to be
tortured to death for simply sharing
that evidence in a book hundreds if not
thousands of the smartest people alive
at that time chose to ignore the
evidence that was right in front of them
thus conforming to the primitive tribal
mentality that the human brain is so
susceptible to and in doing so set
humanity back from forward progress and
I regret to tell you that it's no
different today in fact a very recent
study from just earlier this month
outlined that even the smartest of human
beings alive today are very susceptible
to the tribe mentality nowhere is this
more obvious than in modern politics
however the same exact mindset consumes
much of the scientific and academic
community as well this has long been
painfully obvious to many open-minded
logical thinkers however a scientific
case study now exists that proves that
this is indeed the case that groupthink
mentality is real and is as prevalent as
ever in fact one of my earliest videos
on this channel discussed the topic of
how a cataclysmic event involving an
asteroid strike wiped out ancient
civilization nearly 13,000 years ago and
in that video I discussed several lines
of evidence that are supported by the
most recent scientific studies and
peer-reviewed data
details that most of the general public
have never heard before so real quick
let me just sum up the bullet points of
that evidence as it will tie in to the
premise of this video and really paint
you a picture of just how behind the
curve the mainstream scientific and
academic communities have become when it
comes to connecting the dots on the most
recent empirical scientific data but
seven
things are all proven to have happened
on earth at precisely the same time
roughly twelve and a half thousand years
ago first things first
there was a mass extinction event of 75%
of all mammals in North America and most
of the skeletal remains date to twelve
to thirteen thousand years ago the same
exact timeframe of the recently
discovered Greenland crater now many of
these animals you had no idea ever
existed at all as they don't teach much
about it in the American public school
system but of course we were all
familiar with the notable woolly
mammoths and of course the saber-tooth
tiger but were you aware that camels
originated in North America that's right
and they were known as camel ops and
actually are very similar to the camels
that exists in the Mid East today but
notice the extinction date of closer to
12,000 years ago and hold that thought
as I share a few other fascinating
species that also existed in North
America at that time such as the giant
ground sloth just look at this thing the
claws themselves are larger than my head
and most people have never even heard of
this incredible species and yes they
were around when humans were as well or
how about the giant short-faced bear
significantly larger than polar bears
which are the largest bear species on
earth today and a short face bear is
about double the size of the largest
modern-day grizzly bears but also notice
the date of its extinction some 12 and a
half thousand years ago another
incredible fact is that lions once
existed in North America as well most
people have certainly never heard that
before and also notice their extinction
date of roughly 13,000 years ago but
even cheetahs existed in North America
and again noticed their extinction date
of some 12,000 years ago
just like the saber-tooth Tiger all of
these species went extinct right at the
same period of time basically between 12
to 13 thousand years ago now hold that
thought for just a moment as I share
with you a very recent discovery from
less than a year ago which was a study
published in the Journal of geology
which identified that there were massive
fires even larger than the ones that
took place during the extinction event
of the dinosaurs that scorched at least
10% of all the earth slain
mass with scientists speculating that it
must be related to some unknown cosmic
impact and the date on this twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago the
same exact period of time as the
beginning of the Younger Dryas climate
interval which is marked by a black
matte layer also known as the younger
driest boundary which has so far been
found throughout some 30% of all the
Earth's landmass today covering multiple
continents in spanning from the western
United States to as far away as Syria
this black layer is virtually identical
to the KT boundary which marks the
extinction event of the dinosaurs from
the massive asteroid that hit Earth some
66 million years ago both of these
layers consists of all the trademark
elements of a cosmic impact including
micros perils melt glass nano diamonds
iridium platinum and extraterrestrial
helium to name just a few and again this
layer dates to twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago which just so happens
to be the same exact period of time as
the mass extinction of animals as I just
shared but also when the Clovis culture
which was a massive culture so large
that they occupied nearly the entire
continent of North America and they
mysteriously went extinct some twelve
thousand years ago which scientists have
recently started saying that it is
likely related to some unknown cosmic
impact event and guess what else
occurred at the twelve thousand eight
hundred year mark a sudden and rapid
rise in global sea levels in fact ice
core samples taken from both Antarctica
and Greenland confirm that something
happened to cause a surge in sea levels
with some estimates stating that it
could have been as much as thirty feet
in a 24-hour period
and exceeding fifty feet in just one
single year and when you consider the
fact that most of the world's population
lives on or near a coastline this
basically confirms the some 500 legends
of a flood that have been discussed by
cultures all over the world spanning
across five continents including that of
the Biblical Flood which of course some
will say never happen because it's
impossible for every mountain on earth
to have been covered with water and that
it's impossible to put all species of a
on earth into one single boat but
obviously when you look past that
obviously the Andes Mountains and the
Himalayas when they're not covered
during this event but the very fact that
hundreds of cultures across several
continents all sharing the same story of
a massive cataclysmic flood and now that
we have scientific data that there was a
possible 30-foot surge in sea levels in
a remarkably short period of time this
should get us all thinking I mean that's
like having the 2004 Indonesian tsunami
happen all over the world in one single
day think about that although not
everyone on earth would die a disturbing
percentage would and it would also be a
reset button to the current paradigm of
our current civilization essentially a
reset button as all systems of supply
chain communication electricity travel
etc would collapse in almost an instant
so when we consider the fact that this
twelve thousand year-old crater found in
Greenland is the result of an asteroid
impact to the then continent-sized Ice
Sheet that was more than one mile thick
on average and even exceeding two miles
in thickness in many areas that equates
to some six million cubic miles of water
volume to put this into comparison all
of the Great Lakes of North America
combined equate to 5200 cubic miles
barely a fraction of the amount of ice
that would have instantly melted
following this impact event which of
course explains the anomalies identified
in the ice core samples taken from
opposite sides of the earth you know
this makes me wonder if this is the same
event that was tied to the said
destruction of Atlantis having sunk into
the depths of the ocean which of course
was the topic of my last three videos
but it seems apparent that the west
coast of Africa was massacred by
catastrophic flooding the same area of
the recon structure just something to
think about but I digress if the
flooding wasn't bad enough to make it
all worse this event of twelve thousand
eight hundred years ago was followed by
a 1200 year deep freeze our global
temperatures plummeted so when we
combined the new data of this Greenland
crater dating to the 12,000 year range
there was an initial blast that
essentially created melted
through 30% of the landmass has
identified through the younger driest
boundary layer and then it was
immediately followed by more than a
thousand years of an ice age and this
was all at a time when humans were alive
on earth and they faced what can only be
described as an apocalyptic event
fascinating right but for some reason
none of the articles on this topic
connect the dots on any of the
information that I just shared with you
in fact you will not find one single
mainstream scientist or academic
connecting the dots on any of this
information and what's even more
disturbing is that when alternative
researchers have discussed these things
they have been publicly ridiculed and
then shunned take the example of when
Graham Hancock appeared on a TED talk
with this information in 2016 which let
me first say that I am a big fan of Ted
I have seen many incredibly informative
lectures from their organization and
those presenting on it but when Hancock
presented an abundance of the most
recent peer-reviewed scientific data on
this topic the executive leadership that
Ted decided to suppress the lecture and
then included a pop-up warning at the
beginning of the video which you can see
here and then when you look at the
description they literally state that it
is outdated and accurate information so
I did my own fact-checking and research
and confirmed that no this actually is
the most recent and accurate information
that was conducted by legitimate
scientists that have nothing to do with
Graham Hancock and all he did was
connect the dots on it I mean research
this stuff yourself and tell me that we
don't have a problem here the
suppression of scientific knowledge for
the simple reasons that it contradicts
what has being taught in school written
about in books and textbooks been shared
on televised documentaries and
essentially is the same information that
many professors tendered professors have
been teaching and handing out tens of
thousands of degrees on for decades so
when this information contradicts it all
of a sudden they don't want to talk
about it and the reason is is because
this is people's livelihoods a lot of
people in the scientific community have
become very wealthy and so when someone
comes around or anyone comes around that
contradicts their lifelong works with
new information seems that they don't
want to hear it but this is the same
exact thing that we have seen
demonstrated throughout history the
tribal mental
he truly is a prominent and unfortunate
characteristic of the human psyche and
has clearly affected those in the
scientific community I mean they are
people too right even I got a small
taste of it from my prior video on this
topic
look at these recent comments over the
last few days and I blacked out the
names as I really am NOT trying to pick
on anyone here but it's like this
information is easily verifiable I guess
it just goes back to the groupthink
mentality where people assume that if
it's not taught in school and it's not
in the news well it must just not be
true at all right but I mean what more
proof do people need a twelve thousand
year old video taken from Earth's orbit
showing a massive chunk of iron slamming
into the Greenland ice sheet 12,000
years ago I mean come on but going back
to Ted this evidence of the Greenland
crater confirms what many others have
been saying for years and this was the
last piece of evidence that was needed
the crater as scientists said that you
cannot have an asteroid impact without a
crater so until that evidence is found
none of this can be taken seriously and
you know what and just as Graham Hancock
pointed out in his TED lecture the same
exact thing happened to the scientists
who identified the KT boundary as the
explanation for the dinosaurs extinction
they were ridiculed at first they were
laughed at and when they brought this
theory to the public
it wasn't until someone else finally
found the Chilika Club crater in Mexico
that they were finally vindicated so
here we are nearly a month following
this Greenland crater discovery and Ted
still has all the warnings up on the
presentation that's embarrassing and
they owe it to their open-minded viewers
to not be so patronizing but worse than
that they are trying to suppress known
and proven scientific evidence how is
this any different than the fools that
ridiculed Copernicus Galileo Nikola
Tesla the Wright brothers and so many
others throughout history and you know
what else go to the wiki page on this
topic and at the top they still claim
that the evidence does not exist
so yeah this recent discovery is a
profound example of the inability of
mainstream scientists to connect the
dots on the most recent evidence and
data taken from different branches of
scientific study and developing logical
occlusions thus ultimately slowing the
knowledge and progress of modern
civilization
so as for me I am by no means the first
person to discuss these theories
I am simply making videos on topics that
interest me that I feel that not enough
other people are discussing however I do
take pride on being the loudest one out
there and bringing this information and
other information to as many people as I
possibly can I mean this is this is fun
to me and I was actually a fraud
investigator for a large corporation a
few years ago and so I'm essentially
taking the skill sets I gathered there
and using it to dive into topics like I
said interest me and exposing different
truths that the masses are otherwise not
aware of but what I don't get is why me
a veteran with an MBA why am i the one
connecting the dots for these leaders in
the scientific community like what are
they doing like what's the problem here
are they too busy I don't know creating
definitions and writing them in
textbooks or something and memorizing
them like what's going on so yeah going
back to what I said at the beginning of
this video as far as making some noise
in this channel well it's time to call
out the incredible inaccuracies
involving what we were told about lost
ancient human civilization as all the
dots connect that ultimately ties
together what I've been stating since
the beginning of this channel and this
19 mile wide crater that generated a
blast equivalent to some seven hundred
megatons is indeed the smoking gun
evidence that yes a cataclysmic cosmic
impact occurred approximately 12,000
plus years ago and was a reset for what
was then a relatively advanced ancient
human civilization case in point and
here's a fact that most people do
understand which is that we still have
no idea how the Great Pyramid of Giza
was constructed I mean it is a mystery
we only have theories on how they cut
carved and moved these stone blocks yet
every method proposed ultimately failed
when tested and I'll be coming back to
that in just a second but most people
have no idea that not one single mummy
was ever found in any of the pyramids
ever most people are legitimately
surprised when they hear that for the
first time but check it for yourself
since after all we were taught in school
that yeah the pyramids were built to be
tombs for the Pharaohs so it's
a bit weird that the excluded that parts
about no mummies ever being found in any
of them ever and that there is actually
not one single shred of evidence to even
suggest nor is there evidence to support
that the so-called ancient Egyptians
that we were taught about in school a
4,000 years ago were the ones who
actually built it and you might be
thinking right now well of course
there's evidence how could there not be
well if you consider some definition in
a textbook that wasn't tested by the
scientific method as evidence well you
know it says it right here here's the
evidence sorry guys that's not evidence
and these methods these theories that
they developed 160 plus years ago
apparently they didn't they were based
on no evidence and they didn't even try
to test them at all in fact there is
literally zero ties that connect the
so-called ancient Egyptians to the
pyramids like I've said in other videos
out of the tens of thousands of
hieroglyphs and petroglyphs found
throughout ancient Egypt not one single
one of them shows anything about the
pyramids zero most people are surprised
when they hear that as well but not only
that there is not one single hieroglyph
or petroglyph inside the pyramids zero
yet if you go to any known egyptian tomb
they are covered wall-to-wall in art
guys the pyramids were not tombs they
were clearly something else and I do
discuss this in other videos but the
point I'm making in this video is that
there is absolutely zero scientific
evidence to support that the so-called
ancient Egyptians that we were taught
about in school could have constructed
these structures now I already know that
some people will say and this is because
I've seen comments in Prior videos but a
couple years ago one of the greatest
quick big articles ever came out and
they called it the greatest discovery of
the 21st century that involved a the
world's oldest papyrus scrolls that said
they tell us how the pyramids were
constructed unfortunately most people
must not have read anything other than
the headlines and the actual evidence
shows that not one single word involving
a pyramid is even stated in these
Scrolls all these Scrolls state is that
some wine stone blocks removed on a boat
up the
River to Giza which is something that we
already knew had happened and most
structures found around Giza that are
not the pyramids are without a doubt
younger than the pyramids themselves and
are all made of limestone these Scrolls
literally prove nothing and it was just
a clickbait thing to generate more
interest in the topic of Egyptology and
tourism ultimately what comes down to is
that the civilization that existed
thousands of years before the so-called
ancient Egyptians that were familiar
with they're the ones that constructed
the pyramids and they were wiped out
from the events following the Greenland
impact and over the course of some
twelve to thirteen thousand years all
evidence of how they did it was consumed
by the earth and decayed to nothing gone
from existence forever here's an example
to really paint you a picture of just
how long of a period of time twelve to
thirteen thousand years is scientists
say that if all humans were to vanish
off the face of the earth today the very
last man-made structure to exist would
be the Hoover Dam which the estimate
will weather down into oblivion in some
10,000 years yet the Greenland impact
again is closer to 13,000 years old so
add another 3,000 years on top of that
10,000 years the only thing that would
survive is stone and the pyramids are a
fantastic example of this because after
all the Egyptians were known for being a
Bronze Age culture meaning that their
most advanced technology was primitive
made of a combination of copper and tin
and the theory is that this is what they
use to cut and carve these stone blocks
but if you think that bronze saws were
used to cut these stones then you have
chosen to believe something without any
support of scientific evidence to back
it up which is no fault of your own
because this is what we were taught from
an early age but here's a picture of one
of the best preserved bronze saws from
the time of the ancient Egyptians the
blade is less than two feet in length
and again made of bronze and they want
you to believe that saws like this could
have cut and carved two and a half
million stone blocks as is the case with
the Great Pyramid which let's not forget
these blocks are several feet in length
on average and have six sides and I'm
not saying that to be patronizing but
each one of those six sides was cut with
laser-cut precision and on top of that
there are more than a hundred pyramids
found throughout
Egypt so we're talking about tens of
millions of stone blocks in fact the
only depictions of the Egyptians using
bronze saws at all were on wood and they
were all very small not nearly big
enough to cut the massive size blocks in
the Great Pyramid and here are a few
other examples of saws that they have
found all less than two foot blades but
no rational person would suggest that a
two foot bronze saw would or could cut
the massive 12 foot by 8 foot granite
blocks of the Assyrian in Egypt or with
that level of precision it's just not
possible
no joke apparently various scientists
archeologists and leaders of modern
academia literally decided to skip over
a few parts of the scientific method
when stating how these stones were cut
carved and moved into place and what's
disturbing is that in the last several
years
mainstream Egyptologists have actually
finally tested these proposed methods
and ultimately we're completely debunked
they didn't even finish one single block
guys yet you never heard anything about
it
ultimately they didn't hand out the memo
and they're still teaching and saying
the same exact thing tell me that we
don't have a problem here because that's
exactly what they've done they've been
sharing outdated and proven false
information for decades instead of
saying hey let's open this discussion to
new ideas obviously these methods don't
make sense so what are the other
possibilities they refuse to even
entertain the conversation why is that
like I said before guys it involves
people's livelihoods and money as well
as that groupthink mentality people
don't like change especially when they
thought they knew something their entire
lives yet when people suggest that a
civilization dated thousands of years
prior to the Egyptians
well they say well that's just not
possible but then they chose to ignore
that the Egyptians did leave behind
detailed lineage of the pharaohs dating
back more than 30,000 years mainstream
historians simply ignored and say oh
well this must be wrong
the reality is that there was once a
different age of man that existed here
on earth that was capable of amazing
things and now they are long since gone
and like I've mentioned before which
most people are still not aware of the
site of Gobekli Tepe and Turkey which is
dated to 12,000 years ago 50 times
larger than stone edge 90% of it is
still buried and unseen
this proves that humans were around and
doing amazing things far earlier than
what they're teaching in school and this
site is somehow oriented perfectly to
true north despite the fact that the
North Star was not even in the north sky
some 12,000 years ago so how on earth
did they figure it out to such a an
incredible degree of accuracy you may
have seen the headlines from over a year
ago where modern researchers are
speculating that this site is
essentially a time capsule which is
describing a cataclysmic event on earth
and involved an asteroid think about
that and actually while I'm at it I also
think about this too for some reason
there are pyramids all over the world
as if that's just the normal first steps
of any emerging civilization hey let's
cut a bunch of stone blocks and stack
them on top of each other in the shape
of a pyramid no I'm just not buying that
there was once a civilization that
spanned the earth and they learned how
to do some amazing things and they were
eventually wiped out along with all the
evidence of how they did it there are so
many other examples of ain't our ancient
past that are complete mysteries and I
look forward to building off this
information in further videos but this
is getting a bit long so I'll wrap it up
here but the point is this there is a
serious issue in the mainstream
scientific and academic community guys
and what the world needs now is more
open-minded logical thinkers because
it's 2018 almost 2019 we have incredible
technology to communicate on a global
scale so we need to start getting the
word out and pushing for new ideas to be
thought of because apparently this
old-guard community that's running the
show involving our ancient past they
just they just don't want to change and
they are quite literally ignoring and
not unwilling or unable to connect the
dots on fascinating details guys it all
comes back to that groupthink mentality
and the tribal nature of us as humans
this is just who we are and we need to
be more aware of it but I guess I'll
wrap it up there I have my next video
lined up that will be out in the next
week to two weeks max in fact I have two
videos that will absolutely be updated
or posted in the month of December for
sure so no having to wait on me for
another month between videos thanks for
waiting guys I really appreciate it but
leave me a comment
let me know what your thoughts are on
all of this obviously this is a touchy
subject
many people with lots of opinions but
it's time that we start looking at the
actual scientific evidence that's what
it comes down to but anyways I'll leave
it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
subscribe leave a comment and I'll have
another video out real soon take care
everybody